was würdest du essen wenn du deine
Lebensmittel zu 100% selber anbauen oder
aus der Natur sammeln würdest genau das
werde ich in den nächsten 100 Tagen tun
davon sind jetzt sieben um und ich zeige
euch mal was ich bisher gegessen habe
das sind Apfelscheiben in haselnussmehl
paniert mit gerösteten Nüssen und Beeren
Kompott aber glaubt nicht dass es immer
so Fans sie ist hier gibt's einfach nur
Spiegelei mit Lauchgemüse und Kartoffeln
die Kartoffeln ziehen sich ganz schön
durch habe ich noch Süßkartoffeln dazu
gemacht Kürbis Ei und Pilze ich esse
super viel Apfelmus und natürlich Nüsse
hier haben wir ein hirschsteak mit Eiern
Pflaumenmus und Tomatensalat da drunter
ist noch ein bisschen Zucchinigemüse und
da sind die Reste vom hirschsteak
diesmal mit ein bisschen Paprika wieder
ganz viele Kartoffeln und Pilze und
Rehrücken hier habe ich gebackene Birnen
gemacht mit Pflaumenmus und Frikadellen
das sind Snacks die ich mal im Büro
gegessen habe und hier habe ich selber
Birnensaft hergestellt